when I was taking this script around and
and because it's a love story between a
mother and a daughter I remember every
every man I talked to who was raised
with sisters or who had a daughter said
I know this that's my wife and my
daughter or that's my sister or my mom
and guys who didn't as they said I don't
do women fight like this never seen this
because why would you know that this is
what this relationship is this is Ripley
last survivor of the Nostromo signing
off the movie alien provides a
fascinating case study into how women
are typically written in an early draft
of the script the screenwriter wrote
that the crews unisex and all parts are
interchangeable for men or women the
character of Ripley can't really
reinforce stereotypes about women
because the writer did not have a woman
in mind in the first place in many ways
a largely genderless hero is a great
character to have in a critically
acclaimed Hollywood blockbuster there's
something cathartic about not having to
think about gender in a main character
writing without a woman in mind means a
writer can explore universal human
experiences without worrying about
falling into stereotype it's definitely
fun and exciting to see a character who
doesn't get treated differently because
she's a woman she is a well-written
character with qualities not associated
with any particular gender Ripley in
Alien is a strong woman character
because gender plays a very little role
and her strengths could just as easily
exist in a masculine character Ripley is
just one of the many valid ways to
approach writing women she plays out the
fantasy that gender can be ignored and
that leads to a great movie with a great
lead but a big strength of film is its
ability to tell different human
experiences and the real world is
usually much different than Ripley's
your gender plays a huge part in your
identity there's nothing wrong with a
movie that explores a character without
exploring their gender but a movie that
incorporates gender into the story can
lead to moving and diverse character
arts good evening Carey maybe the best
example of writing women with gender at
the forefront is Clarice Starling in
Silence of the Lambs she stands out in
the masculine dominated world of the FBI
and she is rarely taken seriously by her
masculine counterparts most guys either
subtly check her out or blatantly hit on
her
Frederic Chilton thinks she was only
assigned to interview Lecter because
she's a pretty girl
I graduated from qva doctorate is not a
Charm School good be able to remember
the rules
perhaps the moments that emphasize her
gender the most are the subjective point
of view shots of men gazing at her they
are always looking either in contempt or
attraction clearly marking her as an
outsider and there's more to pointing
out her gender than just to show sexism
in the workplace her gender has clearly
shaped parts of her character arc she
personally identifies with the women
abducted by Buffalo Bill seeing the wake
of one of the girls gives her a
flashback of her father's death the
opening shot of the movie has Clarice
pulling herself up the hill and her goal
in the movie is to save the captured
girls from holes that cannot pull
themselves out of what did you do I went
downstairs I crept up into the barn what
did you see Clarice what did you see
you ran away the climactic finale of the
movie is the ultimate visual link
between the Buffalo Bill abductions and
the men looking down on Clarice in
Buffalo Bill's lair he watches over her
while she's unable to see him don't you
know feel eyes moving of your body
Clarice
of course this scene is creepy and
incredible all on its own but it also
means more because she is a woman and
because we have already inhabited her
perspective as a woman in a world where
men glare at her and objectify her she
has a universal journey of triumph
against adversity but the obstacles in
her path are shaped by the fact that she
is a woman if she were played by a man
the movie would feel drastically
different
unlike Ripley an alien starlings gender
elevates the emotional payoff of the
movie starlings gender is a key
component of her character arc it's a
realistic grounded and important story
but a movie starring a woman doesn't
always have to focus on the struggles of
being a woman
[Music]
the bride and kill bill is certainly not
genderless her story begins when she's
shot at her own wedding while pregnant
immediately after waking from a coma she
goes on her quest for a revenge on her
assailant her former lover bill the
bride embodies the character traits of a
traditional masculine hero revenge is a
classic staple of drama and a common
plot line for narratives typically
starring men in contrast alien and
Silence of the Lambs have more in common
with a survival narrative ripley
survives an invasion of an alien monster
Starling does choose to confront the
villain herself but much of her story
involves surviving events that are out
of her control she has to withstand the
gaze of other men especially in the
climax when she's blind to the villain
staring right at her with Kill Bill the
story is completely driven by the hero
her journey is not a situation she's
thrust into but rather a conscious plan
she devised for herself this quest for
revenge echoes the popular storylines of
old American westerns where heroes
decide to reconcile some past trauma
like Ripley in Alien she fulfills a
fantasy of transcending her gender but
instead of being genderless like Ripley
the bride fulfills the fantasy of being
the action hero archetype traditionally
associated with a man the bride does not
asked gender-neutral she acts in a
masculine way just like the male heroes
before her she's aggressive she takes
charge of the story and she gets her
revenge Kill Bill fulfills the fantasy
that a female character can act like a
male hero the movie gives a fresh
perspective on writing women she is
never a victim in this movie when men
wronged her she always fights back
immediately
Starling had to tolerate the men in her
life but the bride doesn't have to like
the characters before her she's tapping
into the universal fantasy of being able
to write every wrong the trade-off is
that this movie does not seem to tap
into a distinctly feminine experience
what I mean by that is her near-death
feels like this symbolic death of a
delicate more feminine side of her as
appropriate and badass as this
transformation might be there does seem
to be a part of the female experience
missing in this story all three of these
movies write women with some element of
a masculine perspective alien is a movie
where the characters could have been
played by men the Silence of the Lambs
has Clarice interacting almost
exclusively with men and Kill Bill has a
woman playing a masculine role it's also
worth noting that all of these movies
were written into
- by men so it makes sense that there
are some masculine elements in each of
them maybe the last piece of the puzzle
is a movie that embraces an experience
exclusive to women you're not even worth
state tuition Christine my name is Lady
Bird well actually it's not and it's
ridiculous coming-of-age movies
Christine's romantic interests in Lady
Bird are fleeting and unimportant she
paints over her crushes names before
moving out a visual reminder that she
has completely moved on and those
relationships do not have a permanent
effect on her the relationship with her
mother is explored with much more detail
the opening shot instantly shows us the
movies emotional core in the script
Greta Gerwig describes this opening shot
as a modern-day romantic Mary Cassatt
ripoff painting of motherhood Mary
Cassatt was an impressionist painter
known for her images of women in social
and private life unlike many painters at
that time Kasai consistently portrayed
her women with a dignity that suggested
deeper more intimate views of her
characters people look at Cassatt's
paintings and relate to the mother-child
interactions in their familiar
activities the thoughtful expressions of
many of her subjects gives them a
certain intellectual look like there's
more than meets the eye
I think a Greta Gerwig wants to capture
that exact spirit in this movie Lady
Bird gives an incredible look at the
complicated relationship between two
women who would have thought a mother's
opinion on the clothes her daughter
tries on could have so many layers I
want you to be the very best version of
yourself
what if this is the best version this
scene ends with the mom trying to think
of what to say and cutting to the next
scene before she's able to Gerwig noted
that Lady Bird and her mother are most
intimate when they are unconscious in
the first frame we will never see them
be this close to each other for the rest
of the film ironically they also look
extremely similar which Gerwig
reinforces in the match cuts of them
driving despite their similarities these
characters try to be as different from
each other as possible it's this
complicated back-and-forth relationship
that makes their scenes so full of death
you are so infuriating not yelling
perfect the characters are imperfect and
most importantly vulnerable while
there's value in the female badasses
like Kill Bill there's also a strength
in embracing the weaknesses and false a
person can have it's about covering the
entire spectrum of human experience
where a female can act a masculine in
one movie and feminine in another women
directors and writers can give an honest
and relatable depiction of the women
experiences in addition to the fantasies
of FBI agents space explorers and
assassins and it's important that all
these kinds of characters exist for
women each of these characters gives us
a different look into the human
experience maybe a well-written
character played by a woman challenges
you to think a little differently maybe
they challenge you to look without
gender or to see women from a new
perspective if it works it works there's
no wrong way to write women at the end
of the day the great part about cinema
is how it gives us a window into worlds
we wouldn't have seen on our own combine
that with the connectivity of the
Internet and the possibilities are
endless
if you're looking to expand your
understanding across many different
subjects then I highly recommend the
award-winning documentaries on curiosity
stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service founded
by John Hendricks the founder of the
Discovery Channel
it offers over 2000 documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers they have a
great series on Viking women that goes
in-depth on the experience of women in
the masculine culture they lived in go
to curiosity stream comm slash now you
see it for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and nonfiction
series enter the promo code now you see
a when prompted during the signup
process and your membership is
completely free for the first 30 days
[Music]
you